comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui regardez ce que je derrière
moi j'ai deux moniteurs deux nouveaux
moniteurs est ce que vous connaissez un
moniteur est ce que vous aimez les
moniteurs est ce que vous recherchez un
moniteur c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle vous êtes a tout de suite mais
en tout cas j'ai deux moniteurs super
intéressant à vous présenter c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec huawei où il m'a dit
tiens monsieur gros si tu présenter nos
nouveaux moniteurs il ya le mail view il
ya le mec view j'étais alors le night
view il est là le mec views était il est
là sont deux moniteurs qui sont assez
différentes je voulais présenter je vous
les expliquer vous allez voir ces
nouveaux projets sont intéressants et si
vous êtes à la recherche d'un moniteur
eh bien il se peut qu'un un des deux qui
soit fait pour vous deux produits
différents deux cibles différentes sur
les étés on est plus sur une si plus
gaming des personnes qui veulent
vraiment un écran assez long pour des
grandes parties de gagner ça peut être
super intéressant on peut aussi
l'utiliser pour de la bureautique
profite d'un écran très très allongée et
le view sera plus pour de la bureautique
sera plus pour des étudiants sans plus
pour des commerciaux ont donc sans
garder ses deux nouveaux moniteurs signé
huawei et je compte sur mots pour dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires
[Musique]
je veux qu'on commence en parlant du
mail view le maillot c'est un écran 3,2
milliards plein de petits détails que
vous ne voyez pas que vous allez barques
sont super intéressant vous pouvez aussi
bien bien l'utiliser avec un pc de
huawei ou autre comme vous voulez un pc
sans aucun problème pour maintenir
utiliser si un mac et vous pouvez venir
l'utiliser en plus ici avec un
smartphone de huawei est uniquement avec
un smartphone de huawei en termes de
connectique sur le côté vous avez deux
usb à un usb c'est une prise mini jack
et un bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre tandis qu'oddo vous avez du
hdmi 2.0 du mini display port et un usb
c'est qui servira pour l'alimentation
vous avez ressenti cela qui vous permet
de naviguer vous appuyez vous avez accès
à votre menu principal le confort des
yeux activer désactiver une fois vous
validez et deux fois vous sortez pareil
pour la luminosité pourrait venir la
monter ou l'abaisser avec le slider
directement donc ça c'est vachement
sympa et très très facile à faire la
source d'entrée sans fil en wifi si vous
souhaitez en usb c'est en hdmi en mini
displayport bon occitan l'usbc ça me va
très bien je reste comme ça la gamme de
couleurs 98 des ces ip 300% srgb ou
alors en natif des slips et 3 ici ça
devient très très bien et puis ensuite
j'ai les paramètres ici sur l'affichage
leçon la langue l'économie d'énergie
restaurer les paramètres du sinn et bien
évidemment si je souhaite monter le son
je peux le faire extrêmement facilement
je choisis c'est vachement bien parce
que vraiment un côté très satisfaisant
le faisan bout du doigt comme ça c'est
très facile à un champ train d'écouter
de la musique or on m'appelle je baisse
et c'est vraiment cool et ensuite j'ai
raccroché je peux venir remonter très
facilement donc ça c'est vachement bien
c'est discret c'est vraiment planqué en
dessous qui dit moniteur dit facilité
d'utilisation pourrait venir le bc très
facilement il s'arrête et vous voulez en
fait vous pouvez venir le monte de la
même manière pour le régler comme vous
voulez idem pour les petits les ont
faites ce que vous voulez comme vous
voulez comme ça vous arrange vous avez
deux haut parleurs de 5 watts qui sont
intégrés ainsi directement dans votre
pied c'est pas ici que vous aurez leçons
avec plus de basses mais pour profiter
d'une écoute lorsque vous travaillez ça
fera très très bien la faire après rien
ne vous empêche d'ouvrir utiliser une
barre de son en supplément l'intérêt du
format 3 2me sait qu'on va avoir 18 5%
en plus de partis d'écran visible par
rapport à 16 9ème donc si vous voulez
vraiment en avoir beaucoup et je pense
notamment à du montage
vidéo je pense totalement à de l'édition
de photos et bien vous en avez un petit
peu plus contrairement à 16 9ème qui
affichera un peu moins donc c'est vrai
qu'à un vrai confort lorsque vous venez
travailler sur un moniteur comme celui
là donc ça c'est vachement envie alors
ici c'est un tout qui est super
intéressant sais pas si vous le voyez à
regarder c'est que c'est une dalle mate
et l'idée d'une dalle mate ça va venir
atténuer les reflets ici ont des puces
sur une site professionnel c'est un
écran 4 k + 3840 par 2005 160 pixels
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 60
hertz ici n'ont pas fait le choix de
vouloir monter le niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement c'est pas un moniteur
qui fait pour du gaming donc on va pas
chercher à monter davantage 60 hertz
mais ça fonctionne très bien on a débord
hyper fin 6 mm mais on a un ratio écran
bord de 94% donc vous dire qu'ici ça
fait la part belle à l'affichage à
l'écran
1,07 milliard deux nuances de couleurs
donc si vous voulez venir me faire ici
un étalonnage pour une vidéo si vous
voulez venir faire de la retouche photo
vous avez de quoi faire un châssis en
métal vachement élégant c'est un alliage
d'aluminium et on en affichage ici à 98%
des ces ip 3 compatible hd r10 le truc à
savoir ici c'est que le pied fixe à
l'écran peut pas venir le dissocier de
son pied pour le mettre sur un bras
articulé qu'on aurait ici non il est en
un seul bloc c'est absolument impossible
de venir dissocier pour autant il est
vachement beau regarder ça c'est hypra
hypra épuré vous le mettez même de côté
il est super sympa c'est un progrès pour
mettre vraiment qu'elle assure un bureau
en milieu de pièces vous allez vraiment
pas à rougir et la charnière est en
acier en termes de résistance on est ce
qu'il faut qu'elle vous avez en plus
deux micros qui vous serviront pour dire
à faire de la conversation professionnel
pourquoi pas avec vos amis votre famille
vous avez un capteur de champ jusqu'à 4
m donc pour venir converser avec qui
vous voulez que soit pour le travail la
famille et compagnie vous pouvez
facilement et le truc qui est sympa en
plus c'est que ça va venir réduire à
tenir deux cas tous les bruits
environnants donc si vous êtes en
conversation et que vous avez j'en sais
rien moi un ventilateur ou la télé qui
tourne et bien votre interlocuteur ne
l'entendra pas et un moniteur est
certifié tüv rheinland qui va bien vous
protéger contre la lumière bleue il ya
un autre truc est super bien c'est vous
pouvez utiliser les technologies one up
alors one up ça vous servir à quoi à
venir connecter votre smartphone de wet
très facilement vous prenez vous le
posez là haut up il le reconnaît et là
je fais du mirroring c'est à dire que je
viens naviguer sur mon smartphone ça
navigue là bas alors me direz-vous cas
l'intérêt bien vous en avez l'intérêt
c'est si vous voulez faire une
démonstration lancer une vidéo bien vous
pouvez venir le faire donc c'est super
intéressant molitor s'inscrire allemand
dans l'écosystème de huawei vous prenez
vous vous connectez très facilement
juste en posant votre smartphone en bas
mais ça s'est super bien et comme on dit
chez huawei a un système qui est super
sympa pour venir connecter son
smartphone directement sur son pc ça
veut dire afficher sur ce moniteur ça je
voulais déjà présenté dans une
précédente vidéo vous prenez votre
smartphone vous le positionner ici au
niveau de votre pad il se connecte il a
au regard des vous avez votre smartphone
donc vous pouvez utiliser votre
smartphone soit directement sur votre
moniteur soit en passant par votre pc et
qui lui l'affichera ensuite sur votre
moniteur le mail view j'étais raconte
une histoire qui est vraiment différente
ici on est sur un écran incurvé par
contre ici on est sur une cible des ming
donc si vous êtes un gamer si vous
cherchez un bon moniteur pour venir
jouer à des jeux on est sur un moniteur
incurvé de 34 pouces cdu 21/9 écran led
écran 3 cas plus 3444 par 1440 pixels et
on va jusqu'à 350 nice on a un écran hd
r10 certifié lutter contre la lumière
bleue avec la ratification tov ring
landes une dalle mate comme le maître
view et un taux de contraste de 4000
pour un un écran dolby vision vous
monter jusqu'à 165 hertz donc voyez
qu'ici c'est une proposition qui est
tout autre alors moi je la trouve
vraiment intéressante parce que beaucoup
et bien je peux venir faire du multi
fenêtres très facilement vient de poser
à gauche par exemple un navigateur si je
fais du live tweet pour moi typiquement
c'est vraiment le moniteur qu'il me faut
vu que j'ai une très grande surface
d'affichage je peux vraiment m ce que je
veux comme je veux on y retravaille et
aussi une collaboration professionnelle
on peut très bien venir l'imaginé
également dans cet univers là même s'ils
s'arrêtent le gaming je pense que c'est
plus une histoire vous avez également en
dessous en tout cas c'est vachement bien
c'est différent du maître view c'est une
barre de son bar d'options qui est
complètement intégré vous avez deux haut
parleurs 2 x 5 watts et vous avez un
côté tactile ici avec le slice vous
venez montrent elles sont vraies baisser
le son vous avez une petite lumière pour
venir ici paramétrer je vais vous
montrer pendant quelques instants un
écran qui par contre pas être
complètement retirée de son pied donc si
vous avez un bras amovible que vous
souhaitez l'accroché dessus là pour le
coup vous pouvez le faire un écran qu'on
peut venir monter et baisser à sa guise
en fonction de ses besoins qui sont sa
configuration en fonction de son bureau
lâche le connecter en usb c'est la
différence du mec view ici vous n'avez
pas de connexion wifi bons petits points
de détails vous pouvez mettre jusqu'à
trois écrans comme ça oui si vous voulez
trois mecs view j'étais donc ça a offert
une très très grosse configuration
imaginer mmm a fait la démo si par
exemple vous êtes sur un jeu de course
et bien vous mettez votre fenêtre
principale ici l'autre côté eh bien vous
aura côté plus immersive donc si vous
avez des je voulais vraiment voir ce qui
se passe je vais pas dire à 360 et à 180
pour un tout petit peu moins eh bien
avec trois moniteurs mais boutabout
pouvez le faire vous avez deux micros
intégrés pour venir échanger discuter
très facilement avec une réduction du
bruit environnant et elle va venir
capter votre voix jusqu'à 4 m les
connectiques sont planqués au dos
derrière ce qu'il cache qu'on enlève
assez facilement on va retrouver ici de
l'usbc pour apporter l'alimentation on a
deux prises hdmi c'est du 2.0 on a du
display port ici on a encore notre usb
c'est hyper branché un moniteur et puis
on est si une prise jack 3.5 pour bien
branché un petit casque si vous le
souhaitez et autre bonne nouvelle si
vous avez une xbox une playstation ou
une nintendo switch il ya pouvez venir
les brancher directement par contre ici
vous n'aurez pas de 21 9ème vous aurez
uniquement du 16/9 j'ai une petite
molette en dessous qui me permet de
naviguer bon ça c'est sympa et j'ai un
menu qui est assez complet du corps ni
réglée assistant de jeu première
contrôle et l'obscurité la fréquence
d'actualisation et regardez même si je
le souhaite peut venir affiché en
permanence le taux de rafraîchissement
moniteur en temps réel le viseur le mode
d'image dci p3 également dû srgb
gérardmer effets lumineux vous avez huit
modes et 20 couleurs différentes là par
exemple c'est le ruissellement
multicolores mourier plein de couleurs
super sympa j'ai des ondulations comme
ça aussi très jolie regardez là j'ai
l'impression d'être dans k2000 avec qui
il ya un côté pulsé 1 ça vient blessés
ça viens monter enfin bref il ya
beaucoup de possibilités pour venir
paramétrer changer les couleurs donc ça
c'est vrai que ça ne peut paraître un
peu gadget mais c'est vraiment très
sympa car l'expérience ensuite je vais
dans les couleurs du moniteur je peux
venir changer la luminosité le contraste
la température des couleurs est
également basses émissions lumière bleue
alors franchement ça pas très très très
fan le meilleur passeur un côté un peu
verdâtre c'est pascal plus beau vous
avez également la partie images la
source d'entrée à choisir et puis tous
les paramètres système avec le volume du
son les teams de musique que vous allez
écouter sa petite équaliseur en fait que
vous allez avoir à l'intérieur le micro
activer désactiver la langue sans fonds
c'est bien évidemment la transparence a
envoyé il ya un petit menu question qui
est très facile à venir utiliser et
symbolise heures qui est disponible au
tarif de 549 euros 99
regardez comme c'est cool
on se remet du son comme ça très
facilement et avec mon petit doigt jeu
slide jeu baisse je monte je baisse je
monte je baisse on est donc à 699 euros
sur le mec view à 549 euros 99 cents le
méridien gt2 produit vous l'avez vu
qu'ils sont quand même relativement
différent mais tout autant intéressant
dit mme en vous maintenant lequel peut
vous intéresser est ce que vous êtes
plus party gaming sur le gt ou est-ce
que vous êtes plus sur le maïs view
alors un petit ips à vous donner une
petite astuce sont deux moniteurs pouvez
utiliser ensemble avec mon pc au centre
je peux prendre une fenêtre très
facilement regarder par exemple ici et
là déplacer de l'autre côté donc pour
tout ce qui va être live twitch par
exemple c'est une super solution
extrêmement intéressante d'un côté je
n'ai être mon chat de la côte et je vais
mettre ma diffusion enfin on peut
imaginer plein d' usage si vous êtes un
fan des tableurs excel j'en voulais à
nos côtés de l'autre côté vous voulez
j'en sais rien du world vous pouvez le
faire a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez vous maintenant bas en
commentaire et n'oubliez pas si l'un de
ces produits ou voir les deux pourquoi
pas vous intéresse je vous invite tous
les liens en bas dans la description
n'hésitez pas à aller faire un petit
tour en tout cas moi les aime bien je
continue à les utiliser ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle sur ceux des bisous
d'amour portez vous bien et a très vite
ciao